l'Europe est frappée par une chaleur
intense qui s'étend désormais sur toute
la France et le bassin méditerranéen
dans ce contexte compliqué pour nos
concitoyens les propos de votre Ministre
de l'Agriculture samedi sur France Inter
ne sont pas acceptables non nous ne
connaissons pas des températures
normales pour un été
68% des nappes phréatiques sont à des
niveaux sous les normales de saison et
ne sont pas rechargés depuis l'été
dernier le mois de juin était le mois le
plus chaud après celui de 2003 les
Français souffrent au travail et chez
eux dans 25 millions de bâtiments
bouilloire thermique pendant que des
ultras riches que vous récompensez par
des légions d'honneur comme Monsieur
pouyanet PDG de Total énergie
poursuivre poursuivre avec gourmandise
depuis des salons climatisés leur sport
préféré détruire la planète
quand il fait pour mériter les honneurs
de la nation sûrement pas d'avoir agi
pour que les 330 000 sans abris et les 4
millions de mal logés supportent la
vague de chaleur quand ce gouvernement a
présenté le 20 juin dernier son plan de
gestion des vagues de chaleur où
étiez-vous
où étiez-vous début du mois de juillet
quand on parlait de l'eau vous soufflez
sur les braises des émeutes dans les
banlieues
la seule température qui vous
intéressait c'était celle-là alors venir
ici prendre un micro et faire en sorte
d'essayer de faire une polémique sans
vous parce que votre seul objet ça n'est
pas de parler des vagues de chaleur
c'est
madame
panoter que Monsieur Poulet n'a pas été
décoré au titre de la transition
écologique
vous voulez débattre du fond faisons-le
la planification écologique c'est nous
les budgets c'est nous le plan s'il vous
plaît l'adaptation un peu de silence il
vous reste loutrans il vous reste les
fake news à la madame Rousseau sur les
60 degrés et il vous reste pour le reste
le fait de confondre l'écologie
politique avec la sauvegarde de la
planète